hello so as I've said before I generally
try to avoid looking at my YouTube
statistics because I can get quite
bogged down in you know number of
subscribers you can that kind of thing
but I feel like I need to make an
exception to that rule today because I'm
about to hit a million subscribers on
YouTube and I just kind of wanted to
share this moment with you all I'm
currently just sitting here refreshing
my channel page waiting for the number
to topple over to the big the big meal
while waiting I do just want to say
thank you for the last four years or so
of my life I mean pretty much all of the
closest friends that I have are people
that I've met on YouTube all of the
opportunities that I've had to do cool
things in my life have come from being
on this website and you know
fundamentally from people deciding to
watch me on this website regardless of
if you've been watching for a day a week
a month a year or the entire four years
or maybe if you're even one of these
people who's just about just now
watching me right now thank you because
you have given me my life just like on a
plate if it wasn't for you I would I
don't know I have no idea what I've been
doing without this website so thank you
hold on I think we might actually be
there mister is waiting for the page to
load hey there we go
brilliant subscribers ah thank you so
much congratulations
subject Chinese Circle like 13 1 million
subscribers on YouTube ah thanks the
testing is not over I'm sorry
hello oh good you're awake is that oh
you don't remember me I guess that makes
sense seeing as we like to mend
everything
would you awfully mind telling me what's
going on well your little impatient
auntie
if you're thinking of pulling that out I
wouldn't bother it would only make you
die soon ooh okay so I'm just gonna
throw this out there
I woke it up in a place that I don't
recognize a tool wire coming out of my
head and a crazy alien robot lady
talking to me so from what I can guess
my entire life happened to this point
has been a computer simulation at which
the objective has been for me to reach a
million subscribers on YouTube which is
a bit weird by the way and now that I've
reached my target you've woken me up in
there very good go on you're going to
let me go
so close the test is now over thank you
for participating in the Aperture
Science online entertainment program
please report to the incinerator in
three two one
charlie is so Charlie as seriously thank
you for subscribing Lowell ah before I
go I do have a little bit of news for
you all you might have heard me mention
the new chameleon circuit album still
got legs here's the album artwork and
the tracklist oh yeah well the album is
very very nearly almost finished now and
not only that but it's also for those
who are interested available for
pre-order the link to get it is dftba
forward slash still got legs which I'll
put down in the description we've been
working on this album for about six
months or so now and we're really proud
of it so if you do decide to get it I
hope you'll like it and it's gonna be
coming out on the 12th of July that's
all thanks for putting up with me see
you on the flip side yo home dog skillet
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching charlieissocoollike
which makes you like cool